what is up everybody it's anna mack here
for anime uproar and online discussions
about attack on titan are full of debate
about who the real villain is in this
story is it aaron is it zeke is it the
marlenes is it the audience is it the
jaegerists is it carl fritz is it
everyone at the same time and so on i
find that just like in the real world in
attack on titan your opinion on who the
true villain is usually depends on your
own perspective that said i don't often
see much discussion about the fact that
emir fritz the progenitor of the titans
is actually an extremely messed up
villain when you really think about it
this is probably because emir's
backstory clearly showcases the fact
that she was a victim of violence and
abuse and that is absolutely true
however despite starting out as a victim
emir's own choices and actions
eventually turned her into a horrifying
villain and that is what we need to talk
about in this video if you guys enjoy
our attack on titan content and you want
to see more in the future just leave a
quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it helps with that youtube
algorithm just a quick reminder that
subscribing and hitting that bell is a
completely free and also very real way
of directly supporting the channel
finally this video will contain attack
on titan manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned alright so let's talk about
emir's tragic backstory and how she came
to be the legendary progenitor about 1
820 years before the beginning of the
main attack on titan story emir was a
normal human girl whose village was
attacked by ancient aldean soldiers
emir's parents were killed and she
herself along with many of her people
were captured and enslaved by the
ruthless king fritz of eldia they
suffered many cruelties at the hands of
the aldian soldiers including having
their tongues cut out one day someone
opened the gate to a pigpen which
enabled some pigs to escape emir was
blamed for letting the pigs loose and to
be fair she was actually the one who did
it as we learned in chapter 135 of the
manga emir likely did this because she
herself felt just as imprisoned as those
pigs were and so if she couldn't escape
then she could at least give the pigs a
chance at freedom emir's punishment for
this act of defiance was to be hunted
for sport by the ldn soldiers as she ran
for her life from the cruel soldiers an
injured emir came across an unusually
massive tree there was an opening at the
bottom of the tree and emir tried to
hide inside it but when she entered the
opening she fell into some type of
sinkhole filled with liquid
just when it looked like emir was about
to drown alone in the darkness a strange
spine-like creature that resembles a
hallucigenia approached emir and then
attached itself to her spine in the next
moment emir and that strange creature
somehow fused and as soon as this
occurred emir transformed into the very
first titan her titan form was
absolutely gigantic and it easily
dwarfed even the colossal titans
this was the very first titan and this
titan embodied all nine titans shifter
powers that we know today within a
single person emir when he saw this
incredible power the king of elder
changed his mind about killing amir
instead of killing her he made her one
of his wives and used her to expand the
aldean empire that is how emir the slave
became emir fritz emir went along with
all of this and she served the king
loyally despite his cruelty thanks to
emir's titan form the aldians were able
to annihilate their enemies including
the ancient marlians and they were also
able to build the kind of large-scale
infrastructure that the other nations
could only dream of including massive
bridges across mountains huge roads and
other concrete structures and so thanks
to the power of emir's titan the eldian
empire became the dominant power on the
continent eventually emir and king fritz
would have three daughters together
maria rose and sheena the three walls on
the island of paradise were named after
these daughters thirteen years after
receiving the power of the titans emir
died protecting the aldean king when an
assassin attempted to kill the king with
a spear emir in her human form jumped
out in front of him and was killed
presumably the spear pierced her heart
and killed her before she could use her
titan powers to regenerate after the
death of emir king fritz ordered their
three daughters to eat the remains of
their mother in order to inherit the
power of the titans this absolutely
insane plan actually worked and it was
repeated multiple times in the coming
generations until the power of the
titans was eventually split into nine
distinct titan shifters since emir died
13 years after gaining the power of the
titans every subsequent titan shifter
also inherited this curse of emir and
each one of them died 13 years after
becoming a titan shifter but although
she died physically after her death some
aspect of emir's consciousness was
transported to the mysterious land of
the paths and there she continued to
serve the aldian royal bloodline by
mindlessly and tirelessly creating
titans for her descendants even in death
emir continued to be a slave of the
fritz royal family and the founding
titan would faithfully obey any member
of the royal bloodline who gained the
possession of it emir's nearly 2 000
year old enslavement was finally broken
when aaron entered the world of the
paths and convinced her to help him
destroy the world but now we need to go
back and actually look at the life
choices that emir made and the actions
she had taken since becoming a titan
shifter there is certainly nothing
controversial about her actions before
she became a titan she was oppressed and
enslaved by the aldians from a very
young age and she just did what she had
to do to survive her decision to free
the pigs was one of the few decisions
that she made of her own will since
almost every other decision in her life
was forced upon her by her oppressors
and of course as symbolic as this
decision to free the pigs was emir
nearly paid for it with her life however
once amir gains the power of the titans
we have to start looking at her in a
different way even though up to that
point she was clearly a victim of the
aldians once she gains the ability to
become a giant titan she is no longer
just a victim even if we assume that
emir's first few titan transformations
might have been hazy and she may not
have been fully in control we know that
eventually she did gain excellent
control of her titan form because she
was able to use her titan to build
bridges roads and other structures these
are complex projects that required emir
to have a precise control of her titan
form so even though she started out as a
slave after gaining the ability to
become a titan emir was no longer at the
mercy of her aldian captors she could
have used her titan power to crush her
captors if she had wanted to or if she
didn't want to spill any blood she could
have just used her giant titan to escape
from the aldians the ancient aliens of
that era didn't possess any sort of
weapon that would stand a chance against
emir's titan form and since at this
point emir had all nine titan shifter
powers inside of her there were no other
titans who could challenge her as far as
physical power was concerned the aldians
were now at the mercy of emir not the
other way around and yet emir decided to
stay with the aliens to become king
fritz's wife and to use her titan form
to destroy the enemies of eldia this
means that she committed horrible acts
and killed countless people in order to
expand and maintain the aldian empire
among the countless people that she
killed were enemy soldiers but some of
the victims were certainly just innocent
civilians who had nothing to do with the
war some of her victims were almost
certainly just helpless villagers who
didn't do anything wrong just like she
herself was when the aldians attacked
her village and yet she still went along
with all of this not only that but as i
mentioned earlier emir would eventually
sacrifice her own life in order to
protect king fritz from an assassination
attempt the king would thank her for her
sacrifice by forcing her three daughters
to consume parts of her in order to
inherit the power of the titans when i
first saw amir's backstory i speculated
that maybe she gave up her life for the
king because she had lost the will to
live and so the assassination attempt
was only an excuse for her to end her
life by willingly taking on a serious
injury and then refusing to regenerate
but that is not what happened as we find
out later at the very end of the manga
it is confirmed that emir's loyalty to
the aldians and to king fritz in
particular came from the fact that she
was in love with him apparently she fell
in love with her own abuser and she
loved the family that they had built
together so she committed horrible acts
in her titan form killed countless
people and finally sacrificed her own
life because she loved a cruel sadistic
and abusive scumbag like king fritz when
this was revealed at the end of the
story i was not super happy about it and
i even criticized emir as a character i
mean yeah in real life this kind of
stuff does happen unfortunately victims
can fall in love with their own abusers
and then go on to enable and protect
these people because of some warped
belief that their love will prevail in
the end but even though this is not an
unrealistic scenario i still felt that
amir's character should have been
explored more fully and that her
motivation should have been something
other than just a love for a guy who
absolutely did not deserve any love from
literally anyone frankly i felt that
emir was not as well written of a
character as she could have been because
her true motivations were so
counterintuitive and unrelatable some
time later though i realized that emir
was a poorly written character only if
we look at her as a helpless victim who
was just being manipulated by king fritz
and the eldians and i mean yes she was
being manipulated and even after she
became a titan and the audience could no
longer match her physical power i'm sure
they were still manipulating her
psychologically and emotionally but
still even though stockholm syndrome is
a thing nothing could excuse amir's
choices and actions after she gained the
power of the titans emir was just a
young girl when she was first enslaved
by the aldians but we know that she
lived for 13 years after becoming a
titan that means that she did reach
adulthood and was likely in her 20s when
she died and yet even as a fully
functioning adult emir continued to
serve her captors and commit atrocities
on their behalf as an adult who had the
means to extract herself from this
situation and yet chose not to emir must
be considered personally responsible for
these acts king fritz wasn't inside the
titan with her he wasn't holding her at
knifepoint and forcing her to destroy
his enemies she could have used her
titan to take him and his men out or at
least to get away from them but she
didn't instead she chose to kill
countless people in the name of ldn
imperial expansion the cruelty and
manipulative nature of king fritz is
certainly an important factor to
consider in all of this but that still
doesn't justify emir's actions the same
is true of amir's tragic and traumatic
life experiences trauma from the past
certainly has a profound effect on
people and it can cause them a lot of
pain and distress but at the same time
past trauma does not give us
justification to hurt other people being
a victim does not excuse becoming a
victimizer in short being in love with
someone is not an excuse for hurting
innocent people a traumatic past is not
an excuse for hurting innocent people
and a manipulative spouse is not an
excuse for hurting innocent people at
the end of the day emir fritz is
certainly a victim in many ways but she
is not just a victim she is also a
villain as i mentioned earlier when i
first read the ending of attack on titan
the one that included the extra pages i
thought that amir fritz was a poorly
written character because i kept
thinking of her as just a helpless
victim and someone whom i was supposed
to sympathize and empathize with i only
realized later that she is not a
helpless victim she stopped being
helpless the moment she gained the
ability to turn into a gigantic monster
at will and she stopped being a victim
the moment she consciously chose to use
her titan power to kill other people on
behalf of king fritz emir is a victim
who made the choice to become a villain
even though there are mitigating factors
that we have to keep in mind including
her tragic past and the emotional and
psychological pressures that she faced
from king fritz but still these
mitigating factors do not absolve emir
of her guilt
after all we know that emir wasn't just
completely brainwashed into thinking
that what the aldians were doing was
justified don't forget that she
willingly decided to break the rules
that the aldians had imposed on her by
releasing those pigs if she had been
brainwashed she would have just accepted
all of the rules without question but
emir released the pigs because she knew
that what the aldians were doing was
wrong and releasing the pigs was her own
symbolic form of protest it was a
symbolic statement about how she and the
other enslaved people were being treated
by their captors and yet even though she
clearly knew that what the aldians were
doing to other people was wrong she
chose to support and enable them because
she loved king fritz she even left her
own children at king fritz's mercy
because she chose to die protecting him
and we all know how that turned out then
after waiting for nearly 2 000 years for
aaron to liberate her from her servitude
inside the paths emir willingly
supported and enabled aaron's plan to
destroy the world killing the vast
majority of the world's population in
the process aaron told her that they
should destroy this cruel world in order
to attain true freedom and again she had
no issue with ending countless innocent
lives in order to get what she
personally wanted we know that she
watched all these innocent people die
during the rumbling and yet she didn't
really seem to have a huge problem with
it at the end of the day she doesn't
seem to value human life any more than
king fritz himself did so if aaron is a
villain and many people have argued that
he is then emir is certainly one as well
in the end emir stops the rumbling after
seeing mikasa killing aaron despite
being in love with him this act shows
amir that just like mikasa she too can
break out of the living nightmare that
was her love for king fritz but while i
can appreciate the fact that amir's life
was in many ways a living nightmare did
she really need to see mikasa killing
aaron to realize that king fritz was a
bad person and that killing millions of
innocent people on his behalf was a bad
thing no she did not need mikasa to come
to this conclusion she knew the truth a
long time ago and that is why she
decided to free those pigs
but instead of sticking to the
principles she held even before becoming
a titan the titan emir chose to support
a villain and thus she chose to become a
villain herself the story of emir fritz
is not the story of a victim who had no
agency in her life and who was just
being manipulated by everyone rather it
is the story of a victim who willingly
chose to become a villain and that is
the most tragic aspect of this entire
tale emir was a victim of abuse who
decided to join the ranks of her own
abusers and wreak havoc upon the world
killing millions of innocent people in
the process
and so rather than being a poorly
written victim character as i initially
thought she was she is actually a pretty
well written and pretty effed up villain
character
what do you guys think of emir fritz as
a character and do you agree with my
assessment that she was actually one of
the most messed up villains in attack on
titan don't forget to leave your
feedback down in the comments below if
you guys enjoyed this video and you want
to see more videos like it in the future
just leave a quick like it only takes a
second but it helps with that youtube
algorithm and if you're new to animal
pro or maybe you've been watching our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet remember that
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell is a very real and
very important way of directly
supporting this channel you can also hit
me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
for making videos like this one possible
special thank you to kyle salisbury this
man is an absolute mad lad and a
disciple of lord to ego himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including alpha sigma in
grata algital pate heffa the red-haired
fox hinokami and water the toasted chi
cory mcgowan spidey left tanel tungsten
tarkis big buddhist and jeremy cummings
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers angel cruz alicia
octor bonnie parks joy and garcia boy
games kaido might be a duck jessica
rabbit jeremy phillips and alivania if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these amazing people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you